спочатку ми почули, як розбивається скло, я не
знав, що відбувається, але багато
людей бігли, багато людей
плакали, кричали, розмовляли по телефону, ми
знаємо, що щось не так, але ми почали
бачити людей у ​​крові на їхніх обличчях
, були люди, які непритомніли та сиділи
як на підлозі, і так, ми знали, що
щось не так, щоб спробувати запитати людей,
але ніхто не знав, тому мене звуть мінус
Маркус github сором'язливий Лурд кібош бургер
і мить майже лланголлен
позаду свого азаму добре Будда, але воно
підтримує землю зникає Будда I
розповідав про хот-доги і змушував його сміятися.
Я знав, що він у розмірі в’язкості. Я
рідною мовою, у нас великий язик, ви
були на ринку біля собору,
і ми щойно випили глухвайн, а потім,
коли ми виїжджали, проїхала велика
вантажівка  він просто пройшов повз мене повз мою
дівчину, я думаю, він проминув мене на три
метри, точно люди отримали поранення, так,
я розмовляв з двома людьми, які лежали
на підлозі зі зламаними кінцівками, але вони
ми  все буде добре, я бачив, як одного
хлопця тягнуть геть із кров’ю на
обличчі, так мило, що пил, Ллойд
згадав у халепі, ага, автоматичний зарядний пристрій,
слайдер, Жак, Жак, я позначив одного,
де ми бачимо турецькою мовою, я бачу
ефективного, коли маска згадує
епізоду C роздратованих звинувачень